foreign
still look back on your failures and you
are letting it Define Who You Are
how amazing is that he did not let his
failures Define him
but God chose to use him and God has a
purpose for you as well
we do not have stress worry anxiety
because our trust
is in God
hey guys why are some men so resilient
it looks like everything they try to do
to accomplish is just successful
why is that what makes them different
from other men
in my new book bold Pursuit I said the
difference between success and failure
is often a matter of perspective and
perseverance and I'm going to talk about
this a little bit more throughout the
video and when we turn to the Bible 2
Chronicles 15 verse 7 says but you be
strong and do not lose courage
for there is reward for your work
the reason why so many men give up
easily is because they believe a lie
they believe that every setback is a
failure
and they assume that the problem is them
that they are a failure
the truth is that every setback is a
learning experience
it can make you wiser if you let it
you see setbacks are there is going to
happen whether you like it or not it's
just part of life the question is what
do you do with it and about it
C.S Lewis said failures repeated
failures are finger posts on the road to
achievement one fails forward toward
success
you see you need to change the way that
you think about trials and tribulations
and failures especially if you're a
Christian
that they are there to test you that you
need to learn from it knowing all right
this is what happened when I did this so
I'm gonna change the way I do this if
this is going to happen again
so it improves you as a man in fact the
more you fail the more you grow
why because if you learn from it it
changes the way you think and do certain
things and that is how you improve
Albert Einstein said
we cannot solve our problems with the
same thinking we used when we created it
you must learn to see the world aneo
you see failure teaches us perseverance
to keep on trying going going at it
learning from our failures until finally
we made it we have achieved success
this wisdom is nothing new
Solomon wrote about it thousands of
years ago Proverbs 24 16. for a
righteous person falls seven times
and rises again
but the wicked stumble in time of
despair
you see that is how true reborn
Christians are different from the rest
of the world because we will always have
the right perspective and perseverance
living in righteousness according to
God's will
because we live through the spirit
in the middle of failure
and you see James said in chapter 1
verse 2 count it all joy my brothers
when you meet Trials of various kinds
for you know that the testing of your
faith produces steadfastness
and let's steadfastness have its full
effect
that you may be perfect and complete
lacking in nothing
this means we will never give up and we
can easily handle failures if we handle
it through the power of the spread that
is in US
never having stress or anxiety about it
but if you do it through the flesh you
will always worry have stress because
you do not fully trust God and Paul also
says in Romans 5 3 not only that but we
rejoice in our sufferings knowing that
suffering produces endurance and
endurance produces character and
character produces hope and the Hope
does not put us to shame because God's
love has been poured into our hearts
through the Holy Spirit who has been
given to us
and this is how we as men in Christ
reborn Christians can also show the
world that we are different in a way
that we handle difficult times our
trials and tribulations
showing that we do not have stress worry
anxiety because our trust
is in God
we don't have self-confidence we have
God confidence we show them how we deal
with failures with this immense Inner
Strength that we know does not come from
ourselves but it comes from God who
created heaven and earth
but
if you act in the flesh just in your
soul level with your own emotions your
own intellect your own will
it'll do the opposite because then you
look just like the rest of the world
and if you act in the flesh you will
fail
and that kind of failure is not good
in my new book I gave this example
on the night Jesus was arrested Peter
failed miserably in a very public way
Matthew 26 69 to 75 hours after
promising Jesus that he would stay
faithful
no matter what Peter panicked when
someone recognized him as one of Jesus
followers
you see instead of telling the truth and
facing the consequences Peter lie
he denied even knowing Jesus he didn't
just do it once
did it three times he had three
opportunities to do the right thing and
he failed all three of them
after his third denial Peter felt
intense guilt and shame and he repented
for what he had done
he learned from his mistake
then he did something else he showed up
he didn't hide he didn't let his
embarrassment get to him he didn't worry
what other people said about him behind
his back or in front of him
when the disciples got it again
Peter showed up when he heard that
Jesus's tomb was empty he showed up
there too as fast as he could
Peter persevered he refused to let his
failure Define him
you see God chose Peter to lead the
church
how amazing is that he did not let his
failures Define him many of you
still look back on your failures and you
are letting it Define Who You Are
Peter overcame it and led the church a
normal fisherman
but God chose to use him and God has a
purpose for you as well if God calls you
to do something he knows you can do it
and he will equip you with what you need
to accomplish his will for your life
you see that's the difference
between men
who are spiritually mature who walk with
God because they act in the will of God
and that is why God's blessing is on
them and it seems like they are just
successful of everything that they do
they don't have self-confidence they
have God confidence
and that is why they never give up no
matter what they do they know that God
has their back and they walk within his
will God says do this and they do it
they know that God will keep his word
Galatians 6 9 and let us not grow weary
of doing good
for in due season
we will reap
if we do not give up
now most of you who worked really hard
for what you have walking within the
will of God going through very
tough
times
you know most of all that success tastes
a lot sweeter when you went through
hardships and when you persevered Until
the End through failure if you put God
first in everything that you do then you
know the good and the bad it will work
together for good towards you
Romans 8 28 and we know not Wonder we
know that for those who love God all
things work together for good
for those who are called according to
his purpose
now if some of you are in this failure
State make sure that what you're trying
to attempt is the will of God for you
because if it is it will be successful
even if it's hard at times you still
know that you will continue and endure
so if that's where you are you're
fighting through the spirit you're not
giving up you're enduring you're
battling this day in Day Out
then you always need to remember this
while you are fighting through the power
of the spirit remember this always
Romans 12 verse 12. rejoice in Hope
be patient in Tribulation
[Music]
be constant in prayer
now if you want to grow faster
understanding what it means to have God
confidence and not just self-confidence
if you want to grow spiritually stronger
as a man
then please get my new book it's called
bold Pursuit a 90-day devotional for men
seeking the heart of God
you can get the link to the book in the
video description below and also on our
website
before you go always remember this
life is short so don't waste yours
bye guys